A bait and switch that was teased in the trailer,
and an altogether different origin from his comic
book counterpart. It's time to talk about that
big twist. Major spoilers for "Black Adam" ahead!
Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson has promised a
change of pace for the DC Extended Universe,
which has so far failed to truly compete
with the Marvel Cinematic Universe. However,
"Black Adam" may not be the success
that Warner Bros. needs it to be. While
the movie debuted to generally
positive responses from fans,
it has since fallen to a gnarly 42% on Rotten
Tomatoes. Meanwhile, The Verge suggested that
the film has an insatiable need to show how cool
murder can be over telling a compelling story.
Throughout its two-hour runtime, "Black Adam"
shoves a lot of information at the audience.
The movie hits the ground running, opening with
Teth-Adam's supposed origin story, then jumping
ahead to the present day. It's there that we're
introduced to the film's human protagonists,
mother and son Adrianna and Amon followed by
supergroup the Justice Society. But the film's
most significant plot twist happens during its
numerous flashbacks to the Champion of Kahndaq.
From the beginning, "Black Adam" introduces
audience members to the plotline surrounding the
titular anti-hero's origins. The movie opens with
a flashback to 2600 B.C. when the ruthless king
Anh-Kot enslaved the people of Kahndaq, forcing
them to mine the country's natural resource,
a powerful substance called Eternium. A young boy
attempts to stage a revolution to free his people
from slavery, but Anh-Kot's soldiers capture
the boy and sentence him to death. Before the
soldiers can strike the killing blow, the boy
receives the powers of Shazam, becoming the
Champion of Kahndaq, which he uses to kill the
king and end his reign, before being entombed.
The event goes down in Kahndaq's history,
inspiring its citizens as they go through
endless phases of occupation by different
forces. It's not until the Justice Society
arrives that we're finally given more details
about the Champion, when Hawkman reveals that
Black Adam nearly destroyed Kahndaq, which
resulted in his imprisonment, not entombment.
Later in the film, Black Adam reveals that
he's not the legendary Champion of Kahndaq.
The young boy that fueled the nation's revolution
and received the powers of Shazam was, in fact,
Adam's son, Hurut. As the Champion, Hurut was
invincible, so the king's men attacked his
family instead. To save his father from certain
death, Hurut transferred his powers to Adam.
"My son sacrificed his life to save me."
Unfortunately, this gave the assassins the
opportunity they needed to kill Hurut. A
rage-filled Adam uses his new powers
to get revenge for his son's death,
destroying most of Kahndaq before being
brought in front of the wizards of Shazam.
The wizards deem him unworthy to hold
the powers and imprison him for eternity.
"Black Adam" takes much of its inspiration
from DC Comics' New 52 run of the character,
though the comic book origin is a
bit darker than Dwayne Johnson's
portrayal. While Johnson's comic
book counterpart doesn't have a
son named Hurut, his nephew Aman played
a significant role in his origin story.
In the newly reset DC Universe, Black Adam
was given a new spin on his origin story
in "Justice League Volume 2". This version of
Teth-Adam was also enslaved in ancient Kahndaq,
where the nation's dictator murdered his
entire family, leaving only his nephew,
Aman. During their escape, Adam receives a
life-threatening injury before the Wizard
Shazam transports the two to the Rock of
Eternity. There, the wizard deems Aman
worthy of the powers of Shazam, tasking him with
freeing Kahndaq. Aman agrees, but only if the
wizard heals Adam. Aman receives the powers,
and the wizard heals and strengthens Adam.
"I kneel before no-one."
Adam and Aman travel back to Kahndaq
but disagree about how to use their
newly acquired powers. While Adam wants
to exact revenge by killing the dictator,
Aman seeks a more peaceful solution.
Fearing that Aman's plan won't work,
Adam kills his nephew and steals his powers,
claiming he did it for the greater good.
He becomes the Mighty Adam and goes down in
history as the champion that freed Kahndaq.
Similar to "Black Adam," the comics say that
the Champion disappeared. However, Adam turned
against the Council of Eternity that gave him
his powers and killed them. The Wizard Shazam,
the only surviving member, manages to imprison
him, subsequently dubbing him Black Adam.